remember the story of Robin Hood okay
yes I do I've watch it many times okay
let me remind you Robin Hood's merry
band of men in the woods
those were runaway serfs turns out serfs
had a choice they could stay underneath
the Lord on the feudal Manor where they
were probably born or they could try to
break away from that situation they
could run into the forest and join up
with Robin Hood they could get beyond
the reach of the Lord whose reach was
usually quite limited I could set
themselves out to then become what were
called free peasants or yeoman or small
farmers there were in fact all kinds of
options that they had they were risky
but you know leaving your job in a
capitalist economy that's risky too in
fact having a job in capitalism is risky
right now we've got thirty five million
people who just got fired it turns out
employment is risky slaves also by the
way ran away slaves also made revolts
slaves also carved out for themselves
much better conditions than they had
been born into through a variety of
mechanisms the portrayal of all of them
as unfree which is the way the
literature does it and capitalism is
free strikes me as an extraordinary
reach since the vast majority of people
who are employed by a capitalist an
employer either live with that or
they're free to quit in which case their
basic option is to go be an employee of
somebody else
as an employer which is not quite the
escape you might want to recommend it's
a choice but it's not a choice to escape
the system because you really can't do
that in most cases and if you were to
suggest that an employee can go out and
start his own business
most of them really can't
and many of those who do end up in a
situation that many small business men
and women will tell you about which is
they work harder than the people who are
employees and look longingly at the
possibility of going back to be an
employee because however ugly and
unpleasant it was working for yourself
can be even worse
so now let's you touch on a lot of
things so let me take him one at a time
I took notes I'm taking notes here so
you're the professor I'm the student I'm
taking notes all right so let's talk my
Robin Hood so Robin Hood was taking
money from who and giving it to who he
was taking money from the rich and
giving it to the poor that was he that
was his specialty but he was was he was
it really the rich he was taking money
from him was he taking money from the
government who was taxing people too
much Richard you gotta tell the true
story of Robin Hood why and Iran I watch
it a few hundred times so okay wasn't
taking money from the rich he was taking
money from the government that are so
noble they want to do such good things
for the people he was giving it to the
people maybe you and I read all the mr.
Robin Hood story a little watching afar
see maybe the translation was incorrect
I don't know I don't know either but
here's the way I read it yeah he was
against the government because he saw
the government as in the clutches of the
rich and so for him whether he stole
from a rich traveller going through the
forest or he had pitched battles with
the Sheriff of Nottingham if you
remember his arch enemy for him the
distinction between the rich people and
the politicians those rich people had in
their pocket was a difference he didn't
care much about he would take from
either one of them or both of them and
give to the people that they together
were putting on the short end of the
stick yeah I don't if you're if you're
asking about some of the so again it
goes back to the taxation there were tax
into hell out of the people the
government was these noble people that
eventually a greedy person comes and
abused power but if there's one part
that I get from Robin Hood is the
following you do need
laws and you do need lawyers if you look
at China back in 1984 China only had
four law schools you know the whole
Milton Friedman argument when he says
you don't really need laws and you know
just kind of leave it alone that
argument is not gonna work 100% you need
you need long you need lawyers right
they had four law schools in 1984 and
only 2,000 lawyers and China have to
make sure they get a loss or else the
powerful businesses without some sort of
regulation and laws would abuse other
people so that part absolutely I agree
because today you're seeing a lot of
that taking place in many industries
whoever can get the best lobbyists that
can pay the most money to people that
they can control and campaign with they
can pass a lot of the laws but when you
say the rich and the poor I I sometimes
wonder what direction you go from there
as far as the you know the the people
that are employees who cannot be rich
you're saying poor people cannot be rich
bridgid do you know how many people ask
your father taxes that they made a
million dollars how many people in
America do you think file taxes that
they made a million dollars what do you
think that number is income what do you
think I'm actually curious to know what
you think good question
no statistic in my head comes to my mind
but it's from the IRS it's a government
organization that you trust yes listen
you want to paint me as an advocate of
the government I'm not that's not I
don't trust the government I don't see
the government as an eating god man
because we're on the same page there
that's good okay I don't know what
actually I'm curious to know what you
think so you and I are having a drink
together I don't know if you drink we're
having coffee hot chocolate we're having
a beer and you're talking we're shooting
do you know what and I say Richard how
many people last you made a million
dollars in taxes what would you say
four million four million people you
said million dollars yeah so the way you
did the math was 330 million you did one
percent little over one percent of the
330 million half of them can't work
because their kids are they're older so
working employees we have hundred we
have a hundred fifty million people
America that actually work and added 150
million that work 1% makes around 460 1%
makes 460 if you know how they say
you're in the 1% you make 460 500,000
people last year filed in their income
taxes that they made over a million
dollars five hundred thousand it's not
like it's only 18 people it's not like
it's only 62,000 people
it's 500,000 people last year made a
million dollars in America if you and I
were talking and you were to say I climb
Mount Everest and I'm the only one that
did it after 65 years old Judy only
wanna be like oh my I could never do it
I have a hard time sometimes climbing my
office here you know three stories I'm
going crazy you climb Mount Everest
that's impossible
I get that argument that not everybody
can climb Mount Everest but if Richard
500,000 people in America can make a
million dollars don't you think 1
million people can make a million
dollars don't you think more people can
make a million dollars no you don't
believe that no not from one minute
seriously yeah what's your argument
honey how do you argue that part though
so 500,000 Richard made a million
dollars last year that's a lot of people
right but in order for there to be
500,000 people who make a million then
there have to be an awful lot of people
who make very little
you
[Music]